well joining us here now ben shapiro
editor-in-chief of the conservative news
website the daily wild and host of the
ben shapiro show thanks traveler i kick
so how much damage to this republican
president just due to the republican
party by throwing his support behind
this republican senate candidate who
like other things is an accused child
molester well i mean i don't think it's
helping me in the image of the
republican party among undecided voters
among young among people who are looking
at which party is going to look for some
sort of moral standard here obviously do
i think that trumps saying this has made
a large difference in how people
perceive the republican party no because
we already were having the roy more
debate before trump point in and we had
this debate partially about trump during
the 2016 election so it seems to me that
in terms of additional damage that he's
doing i'm not sure he's doing for -
additional damage but he's continuing to
double down on the damage that's already
been done okay listen to this this is
how a donald trump rationalized his
support for roy more he totally denies
it he says it didn't happen and you know
you have to listen him also he actually
said that like about ten times that you
roy more denies this is this all just
because Donald Trump is desperate for a
political win he wants to get his tax
cuts through and so he needs that
Republican seat in the Senate because it
seems like there's more I really don't
think it's that much about about the tax
cuts per se I don't even think it's
about a Supreme Court seat per se if
that were to come up I think that
there's this binary model that Trump has
relied on politically which is you got a
vote for Republicans because Democrats
are worsen it doesn't matter what the
Republicans have done that's part of it
for Trump the the most obvious sort of
political out here is to quietly back
more or two to at least say as little as
possible here I think there also is the
possibility that if you were to go after
more really hard hear about these
allegations that the next can the warm
that's open is we go back to all the
allegations that were made about Trump
personally in 2016 and with that I just
want you does Donald Trump sort of
identify in a way with Roy Moore you
know Roy Moore is the outsider he's you
know he's been accused of all these
allegations of sexual harassment Donald
Trump was accused of sexual harassment
more denies that Donald Trump denies it
you Mitch McConnell does not like Roy
Moore Mitch McConnell does not like
Donald Trump he does not see himself in
Mitch McConnell he kind of sees himself
more in roy more you know
don't want to get into too you know
psychoanalyzing the presidents of the
United States it seems like a dangerous
business but what people doing it yeah
sure I do business yeah I do think that
that you know the president tends to
side with whomever he feels there's a
wave of media attention against that
seems to be his sort of his gut reaction
at least people who he is politically
aligned with and so for more he sees the
tsunami of media attention and
apparently there's an article in
Politico today about how he felt like
this was all staged and maybe the
accusers were not telling the truth
yeah I don't know if that that's if
that's identifying with with more as as
though more as innocence but you know I
don't think it's unfair to say that the
president feels very anti media and and
he does abide by a simple rule which is
the enemy of mana means my friends the
media hates ROI more than maybe but will
read more as my friend how difficult
will it now be for Republican lawmakers
in Washington essentially to force more
out of this campaign to say some kind of
write-in campaign well even refused to
seat he's not leaving I mean this is the
only a person who may have been able to
come down with both feet and try to push
more out of the race was the president
right but he might have been able to say
listen everybody in Alabama this is a
disaster he's running at the very least
from a political standpoint he's now
running neck-and-neck with doug jones he
may be running behind doug jones in a
state that would go 6633 republican on a
typical election so you know if you
really want to win the seat abandon roy
more move over to jeff sessions for
example he could solve to two you know
two problems he hasn't liked jeff
sessions apparently could move them out
of the AG spot and have him run as a
write-in candidate now bama trump didn't
do that Roy Moore was was disinclined to
drop out anyway because that's that's
Morris kind of mo a last question it's
kind of related it's about a piece you
wrote on Tuesday the National Review
it's about preventing sexual harassment
he's part of it
conservatives have long proclaimed that
man left unchecked who like like pigs
with regard to women so you argue that
what's needed is a return to traditional
social norms like sex would be connected
with marriage thus cementing the
connection between sexual activity and
commitment carefully cultivated rules of
conduct between men and women including
in many religions prescribe physical
contact expectation that men would
protect women in
civiles fashion it sounds like you're
saying it's let's go back to the good
old days there are also much better yeah
well it's not really that it's that
there were certain
the basis for a lot of conservative
thought is that human beings are
inherently flawed that we are sinful
people who are capable of doing bad
things and that there are all these
rules in place to protect women against
men like a lot of these rules were
designed to keep men in check this is
why men were taught to be gentlemen now
not all men acted like that and I think
what the feminist movement and a lot of
the left said was these rules didn't
keep men in check what if we just get
rid of all the rules and now what's
happening is a sort of an ad hoc
formation of new rules but these new
rules don't really seem to be
particularly coherent so you'll see same
the same people saying that it's totally
fine for men men and women to go out to
bars at night whether he's an employer
and she's an employee and they get drunk
together and then if they have sex and
everything goes well it's fine but if
they get drunk together and they have
sex and it doesn't go well and she
doesn't you know and she's unhappy about
it then this was some sort of
exploitative situation you can see this
in the splitter down Monica Lewinsky now
right you're actually seeing some people
on the Left saying that that Clinton
should have resigned over Monica
Lewinsky at the time they weren't saying
that they were saying was a fully
consensual relationship what I'm saying
is that whether you accept the
conservative rules or or a new set of
rules we have to have some set of rules
that acknowledge that no matter how much
we wish that men would stop being pigs
men are going to be pigs except if there
are rules in place and just shouting at
the wind saying I wish men would be
better I wish men would be better too
and that's why you know I intend on
teaching my son standards and my
behavior and teaching him to be a
gentleman is what my father taught me
but I think that living in a standard
bliss world and then just magically
expecting human nature to change I think
is a recipe for disaster yeah you know
getting it I was Mike Pence the vice
president who would not either learn
with a woman who's not his wife I mean I
don't think there's anything wrong with
my Pence's rule for Mike Pence you know
I think the idea that this is by the way
this has been a long-standing religious
tradition and Orthodox Judaism is that
men and women are not supposed to be
alone in rooms with with members the
APUs ex who are not there their spouses
but you're not saying that that you know
you know 20-30 years ago that there was
no sexual rights of course women weren't
being bothered
I mean at least now that there seems we
yeah it is safe for women to come out
and say I was sexually harassed by that
guy that's great and I wish that had
happened you know 20 or 30 years ago I
wish that happened for years in fact I
think that some of what drove the
feminist movement was exactly that right
was a rebellion against the the madmen
culture this idea that there is this
repressive hierarchy that was treating
women as sex objects but the problem is
are women not treated as sex objects now
because seems to me that every single
person in Hollywood that I know of is
now being accused of this stuff and that
is the most leftist permissive society
in America so what exactly happened here
the point that I'm making is that the
problem was not necessarily some of the
rules the problem was failure to adhere
to the rules the left tore down all the
rules and now they're trying to create
rules through these backdoor mechanisms
like yes means yes in California those
rules in many cases are gonna end up
being more Puritan istic than a lot of
the original rules right the rules in
California this yes means yes rule is
basically I'm supposed to have a lawyer
there with me when I'm having you know
sex with somebody going down the
checklist of consented that's that seems
to me a lot less doable than an
expectation that you're only having to
the person you're married to we're out
of time but I guess the end of the day a
return to common decency yes yeah
exactly
Ben I wanted to have you in for a long
time it's back to talking family I
appreciate it appreciate thank you